you guys that is just one of the many
fun things we have planned for you
tonight okay this all checks out looking
good excuse me can i help you oh hey
sorry to interrupt but i need to test
out this new voice recognition software
do you mind i mean i guess it's okay but
hurry up we're in the middle of a show
oh
hey
look at that
hey everybody
i'll make this quick
uh computer turn lights to blue turning
lights blue
oh whoa
that's cool well i doubt it'll
understand me and taric though those
types of software are notorious for not
recognizing black voices oh you won't
have that problem with this one it's
from a company in england that claims
they've created a voice recognition
software that more accurately recognizes
black voices
yeah i read about that it's supposed to
be more accurate than apple or google oh
okay i wanna try it
computer turn the lights to white okay
sis i got you turn it lights to white
and then we turn it up ew
what the hell was that
it's pretty cool right
i thought this show would be a great
place to beta test it since it has so
many careful
so many very talented diverse people
good save tarik why don't you try it all
right uh computer play music what's good
fam oh
that's what's up you know i got you cuz
what you want some biggie young thug
losey burp
uh i was thinking more like harry styles
come on dog i hear your voice
i know what you want to listen to my guy
playing r kelly no no
no no no
here let me try computer play music
playing leonard skinner no thank you
computer girl right ain't nobody trying
to hear no damn leopard skin yard
leonard skinnered you got it buddy i
could listen to some free bird hey man
i told you i ain't playing that [ __ ]
for you
now let me play some lil baby
baby baby d or any of the rat babies i
got you what is wrong with this software
i guess there's still a few bugs to work
out you think
look i'd rather have it ignore me than
do whatever this is who programmed this
computer who wrote your code code
switchers
oh
don't say oh you don't know what that
means
i do not let's get rid of this thing
okay computer throw yourself in the
trash oh he said you're trash but he
said you're trash
[Music]
you